THE WAY FOR THESE QUESTIONS TO
BE ASKED.
>> THAT INVESTIGATION GOING ON
IN GEORGIA.
LET'S GO TO NEW YORK RIGHT NOW.
JURY SELECTION BEGAN TODAY IN
THE TRUMP ORGANIZATION CRIMINAL
TAX FRAUD TRIAL THAT'S JUST
BEGINNING.
WHAT'S THE LATEST?
>> AFTER ALL THE YEARS, WOLF,
THIS CASE REPRESENTS THE CLOSEST
THAT REALLY PROSECUTORS HAVE
GOTTEN TO THE FORMER PRESIDENT'S
COMPANY, TRUMP ORGANIZATION.
HE, OBVIOUSLY, IS NOT IMPLICATED
IN ANY OF THE WRONGDOING THAT IS
ON TRIAL HERE, BUT WE KNOW WE'RE
EXPECTING THE STAR WITNESS TO BE
ALLEN WEISSELBERG, A FORMER CFO
OF THE ORGANIZATION.
HE HAS PLEADED GUILTY TO NOT
PAYING TAXES ON SOME OF HIS
COMPENSATION FROM THE TRUMP
ORGANIZATION.
AND WE'LL SEE WHETHER WHAT WE
HEAR ON THE STAND AND FROM THE
PROSECUTORS GETS CLOSE ENOUGH TO
THE FORMER PRESIDENT THAT THERE
IS SOME SORT OF POLITICAL DAMAGE
THAT MAY COME FROM IT.
THIS IS ONE OF THE REASONS WHY
IT'S REPORTED THAT THIS IS ONE
REASON WHY IT APPEARS THAT TRUMP
HAS NOT ACCEPTED AN OFFER TO DO
A PLEA DEAL WITH ALVIN BRAGG,
THE DISTRICT ATTORNEY IN
MANHATTAN.
THERE WAS AN OPPORTUNITY TO DO A
PLEA AGREEMENT, THEY DECIDED
THEY WANTED TO GO TO TRIAL.
AND SO THE JURY SELECTION BEGAN
TODAY AND WE'LL SEE HOW LONG
THIS GOES.
>> TRIAL IS GOING ON RIGHT NOW.
THANKS VERY MUCH, EVAN, FOR
THAT.
>>> LET'S GET MORE ON ALL OF
THIS.
JOINING US, CNN POLITICAL
ANALYST, MAGGIE HABERMAN, SENIOR
POLITICAL REPORTER FOR "THE NEW
YORK TIMES," AND HER NEW BOOK IS
ENTITLED "CONFIDENCE MAN: THE
MAKING OF DONALD TRUMP AND THE
BREAKING OF AMERICA".
MAGGIE, THANKS FOR JOINING US.
YOU'VE REPORTED EXTENSIVELY ON
THE UPS AND DOWNS OF TRUMP'S
BUSINESS IN NEW YORK, INCLUDING
IN YOUR NEW BOOK.
HOW MUCH DO YOU THINK IT PAINS
TRUMP TO SEE THIS TRIAL GET
UNDER WAY TODAY?
>> ANYTHING INVOLVING TRUMP'S
BUSINESS IS PAINFUL FOR HIM,
WOLF, IF IT INVOLVES A COURTROOM
OR A PROSECUTOR OF ANY KIND.
OBVIOUSLY HE DID NOT GET CHARGED
PERSONALLY, AS YOU DISCUSSED,
AND THAT IS FOREMOST IN HIS
MIND, THE THING HE'S HOPING TO
AVOID.
BUT THIS TARNISHES THE COMPANY
FURTHER AT A TIME WHEN THE
COMPANY IS NOT EXPANDING.
AT BEST, IT IS IN STASIS, AND
ALLEN WEISSELBERG IS GOING TO BE
THE STAR WITNESS FOR THE
PROSECUTION.
THERE ARE FEW PEOPLE WHO HAVE
BEEN AROUND DONALD TRUMP ABOUT
SUCH KNOWLEDGE OF HOW THE
BUSINESS WORKS AS ALLEN
WEISSELBERG.
SO EVEN IF THIS DOESN'T
PERSONALLY TOUCH ON TRUMP
CRIMINALLY, THIS IS NOT GOING TO
BE A SERIES OF GOOD NEWS DAYS
FOR HIM.
>> GOOD POINT.
ON TOP OF THIS, THE FORMER
PRESIDENT, AS WE ALL KNOW, IS
NOW FACING A SUBPOENA FROM THE
JANUARY 6th SELECT COMMITTEE,
SOMETHING THE COMMITTEE VICE
CHAIR LIZ CHENEY SPOKE ABOUT ON
SUNDAY.
WATCH THIS.
>> SO THE COMMITTEE TREATS THIS
MATTER WITH GREAT SERIOUSNESS
AND WE ARE GOING TO PROCEED IN
TERMS OF THE QUESTIONING OF THE
FORMER PRESIDENT UNDER OATH.
IT MAY TAKE MULTIPLE DAYS AND IT
WILL BE DONE WITH A LEVEL OF
RIGOR AND DISCIPLINE AND
SERIOUSNESS IT DESERVES.
HE'S NOT GOING TO TURN THIS INTO
A CIRCUS.
THIS ISN'T GOING TO BE HIS FIRST
DEBATE AGAINST JOE BIDEN AND THE
FOOD FIGHT THAT BECAME.
THIS IS FAR TOO SERIOUS OF A SET
OF ISSUES.
>> SO, MAGGIE, YOU'VE COVERED
TRUMP FOR A LONG TIME.
IS THAT TRUMP'S ENTIRE M.O., TO
TRY TO TURN THINGS INTO A
CIRCUS, AS SHE SAYS WILL NOT
HAPPEN?
>> THERE'S NO QUESTION THAT HIS
ENTIRE M.O. IS TO TRY TO
DOMINATE WHATEVER SITUATION HE'S
IN, ESPECIALLY IF CAMERAS ARE ON
HIM.
HE HAS TOLD PEOPLE THAT HE WOULD
LIKE TO TESTIFY LIVE, THAT'S THE
CONDITION HE WOULD BE OKAY WITH.
THERE WERE SOME OTHER CONDITIONS
AS WELL.
I THINK THAT SHE IS MAKING
PRETTY CLEAR THE TERMS HE WOULD
LIKE TO SET ARE NOT THINGS THE
COMMITTEE ARE NECESSARILY GOING
TO AGREE TO.
AND IT'S NOT CLEAR THAT HIS
LAWYERS ARE FINE WITH HIM DOING
THAT.
HE HAS, OVER TIME, OVER A VERY
LONG PERIOD OF TIME, DURING THE
PRESIDENCY AND PRIOR, HAD A
DESIRE TO TRY TO TALK HIS WAY
OUT OF ANY INVESTIGATION.
AND I THINK THAT HIS LAWYERS,
YOU KNOW, EVEN THOSE WHO ARE
MORE PERMISSIVE WITH HIM, ARE
AWARE THAT COULD BE PROBLEMATIC.
>> TRUMP CAN FOLLOW THE MARK
MEADOWS ROUTE AND PROVIDE JUST
ENOUGH COOPERATION TO AVOID
CONSEQUENCES, OR THE STEVE
BANNON ROUTE, BUT HE ONLY NEEDS
TO RUN OUT THE CLOCK ON THE
COMMITTEE.
WHAT DO YOU EXPECT?
>> I EXPECT THAT YOU ARE GOING
TO SEE HIM RUN OUT THE CLOCK ON
THE COMMITTEE, WOLF.
I DO NOT EXPECT THAT HE'S GOING
TO GO EAGERLY IN WHEN ALL SIGNS
ARE THAT THE HOUSE REPUBLICANS
ARE GOING TO TAKE CONTROL OF THE
HOUSE BACK AND THEN THE WIDE
EXPECTATION IS THAT IN A FEW
MONTHS THIS COMMITTEE WILL
DISAPPEAR BECAUSE OF THAT.
>> OVER THE WEEKEND THE FORMER
PRESIDENT AGAIN TEASED YET
ANOTHER PRESIDENTIAL RUN.
WHAT'S THE LATEST YOU'RE HEARING
ON HIS THOUGHTS ABOUT A 2024
PRESIDENTIAL RUN, AS HE FACES
THESE MOUNTING LEGAL TROUBLES
RIGHT NOW AS WELL?
>> LOOK, I THINK THAT HE VERY
MUCH BELIEVES THAT THE PROSPECT
OF THE CAMPAIGN AND POSSIBLY THE
PRESIDENCY AFFORD HIM SOME ARMOR
AGAINST THESE INVESTIGATIONS.
I THINK THAT FACTORS INTO HIS
DECISION.
I ALSO THINK THESE ARE --
POLITICS IS A DISTRACTION FROM
EVERYTHING ELSE HE IS DEALING
WITH.
SO IT IS WIDELY ANTICIPATED BY
PEOPLE AROUND HIM THAT HE WILL
ANNOUNCE A CANDIDACY SOON AFTER
THE MIDTERMS.
>> MAGGIE HABERMAN JOINING US,